is there a way to change that
policy wise so this is this is a much
bigger thing that you're speaking to
which i
i love in terms of the mit
uh engineering approach to public health
is there a way to push this is this is
this a political thing like where some
andrew yang type characters need to like
uh start screaming about it
is it uh more of an elon musk thing
where people just need to
build it and then on on twitter start
talking crap to
the politicians not doing it what it
what what do you
what are the ideas here uh i think it's
a little both
i i think it's political on the one hand
and i've certainly been talking to
congress a lot
talking to senators are they receptive
oh yeah i mean that's the crazy thing
everyone but the fda is receptive i mean
it's it's astounding i mean i advise
you know informally i advise the
president
and the president-elect's teams i talked
to congress i talked to senators
governors you know and then all the way
down to
you know mayors of towns and and things
and um
i mean months ago i held a round table
discussion with mayor garcetti uh as the
mayor of la
and i brought all the uh all the
companies who make these things this was
in like july or august or something i
brought all the companies to the table
and said okay how can we get these out
and unfortunately
it went nowhere because the fda won't
authorize them as public health tools
the nice thing is that this is one of
the nice and frustrating things this is
one of the few bipartisan things
that i know of and like you said it's
it's a real solution
yeah lockdowns aren't a solution they're
they're a
emergency band-aid to a catastrophe
that's currently happening they're not a
solution
and they're definitely not a public
health solution if we're taking a more
holistic view of public health which
includes
people's well-being it includes their
psychological well-being their financial
well-being
you know just stopping a virus if it
means that all those other things get
thrown under the bus
is not a public health solution it's a
it's a
it's a myopic or or very
tunnel visioned approach to a viral
virus that's spreading
this is a simple solution with
essentially
no downfall you know there is no nothing
bad about this it's just giving people
uh a result and it's bipartisan
you know the most conservative and the
most liberal people everyone just wants
to know their status you know nobody
wants to
have to wait in line for four hours to
find out their status on monday
uh a week later on saturday you know it
just doesn't make any sense it's a
useless test at that point
and everyone recognizes that so why why
do you think uh like the mayor of la
why do you think politicians are going
for these um
from my perspective like kind of
half-assed lockdowns
which is not so i have seen good
evidence that like
a complete lockdown can work but that
in in theory it's just like communism
and theory can work
like theoretically speaking but it just
doesn't at least in this country
we don't i think it's just impossible to
have complete lockdown
and still politicians are going for
these kind of
lockdowns that everybody hates
that's really destroy really hurting
small businesses
um like why are they going big
businesses and
yeah all businesses uh but like
basically
not just hurting yeah they're destroying
small businesses right
which is going to have potentially
i mean long lasting yeah i've been
reading
as i don't shut up about the the rise
and fall of the third reich and
you know there there's economic effects
uh
that uh take a decade to you know
there's going to be long lasting effects
that may uh may be destructive to the
very fabric of this nation so
why are they doing it and why are they
not using the solution is there is there
any intuition i mean you've said that
fda has a stranglehold i guess on this
whole
public health problem is that is that
all it is
that's honestly it's pretty much all it
is
um the company so the somebody like
mayor garcetti or governor baker
uh cuomo newsom any of the uh
dewine i i've talked to you know i've
talked to a lot of governors in this
country at this point
and and of course the federal government
including
including the president's own teams you
know and and uh
and the heads of the nih the heads of
cdc about this
the problem is the tests don't exist
in this country at the level that we
need them to right now
to make that kind of policy to make that
kind of program
they could but they don't and so
what that means is that when mayor
garcetti says okay what are my actual
options today
despite these sounding like a great idea
he looks around and he says
well they're not authorized you know
they don't exist right now for
at-home use and from his perspective
he's not
about to pick that fight with the fda
and it turns out nobody is
why why are people afraid of uh it seems
like a easy structure
to fight it's like well it's not a so
they don't see it as a fight they think
that the fda is the end-all be-all
everyone thinks the fda is the end-all
be-all
and and so they just def everyone is
deferential
including the heads of all the other
government agencies because that is
their role
but what everyone is failing to see is
that the fda doesn't even have a mandate
or a remit
to evaluate these tests as public health
tools so they're just falling in this
weird gray zone
where the fda is saying look we evaluate
medical products
that's the only thing that i meant like
tim stenzel head of in vitro diagnostics
at the fda
he's doing what he's what his job is
which is to evaluate public uh which is
to evaluate medical tools
unfortunately um this is where i think
the cdc has really blundered
they haven't made the right distinction
to say look
okay the fda is evaluating these for
doctors to use and all that
uh but you know we're the cdc and we're
the public health agency of this country
and we recognize that
these tools uh require a different
authorization pathway and a different
use
not just the difference between medical
devices and public health
and i guess fda is not designed for this
public health especially in emergency
situations
and they they actually explicitly say
that i mean when i go and talk to tim
you know he's a very reasonable guy but
when i talk to him
he says look we don't we just do not
evaluate a public health tool if you're
telling me this is a public health tool
great go and use it
and uh and so i say okay
great we'll go and use it and then the
comment is but
you know does it give a result back to
somebody i say well
yes of course gives a result back to
somebody it's being done in their home
so well then it's defined as a medical
tool can't use it
so it's stuck in this gray zone where we
unfortunately there's this weird
definition that any tool
any any test that gives a result back to
an individual
is defined by cms centers for medica
medicaid services as a medical device
requiring medical uh authorization but
then you go and ask it gets crazier
because then you go and ask
sema verma the head of cms
you know okay can these be authorized as
uh as public health tools and not fall
under your definition of a medical
device
so then the fda doesn't have to be the
ones authorizing it as a public health
tool
and sima verma says oh well we don't we
don't have any jurisdiction over
over uh point of care and uh and sort of
rapid devices like this we only have
jurisdiction over lab devices
so it's like nobody has ownership over
it which means that they just keep they
stay in this purgatory of
of not being approved and so this is
where i think
frankly it needs a president it needs a
presidential order to just unlock them
to
say this is more important than
you know having a prescription and in
fact i mean really what's happening now
because there is this
sense that tests are public health tools
even if they're not being defined as
such the fda now is pretty much
not only are they not authorizing these
as public health tools
what they're doing by by authorizing
what are effectively public health tools
as medical devices
they're just diluting down the practice
of medicine right
i mean his answer right now
unfortunately is
well i don't know why you you want these
to be sort of available to everyone
without a prescription we've already
said that a doctor can write a whole
prescription for a for a whole
college campus it's like well if you're
going in that direction then that's no
longer medicine
having a doctor write a prescription for
a college campus for everyone on the
campus to have repeat testing
now now we're just in the territory of
of eroding medicine
and eroding all of the legal rules and
reasons that we have prescriptions in
the first place
so it's just everything about it is just
destructive
instead of just making a simple solution
which is
these are okay as public health tools as
long as they meet x and y metrics
go and cdc can put their stamp of
approval on them
you